hi my name is goand I'm a global shaper
from the Bangor hub
I represent Emerson leadership channel
one question I always had in my mind you
see a lot of big cities Bangalore Mumbai
Delhi but whatever little small towns
and villages I believe these are places
which are going to deliver the growth in
the next 10 years next 20 years this
will be the growth engines in India so I
always had a question in mind how can
tackle the problems they are facing in
these places how can you improve their
livelihood how can you bring them into a
sustainable mode I've got a lot of
fanswers for all these questions when I
came to the Indian economic summit
so the next step is to actualize some of
these ideas which I have got from the
forum and the summit Thanks